Speaker 1: Let's go next to why don't we go
to Max from Illinois, Max from Illinois. You're
on the air.
Speaker 6: Hi, Dana. Hello for having me on.
Pleasure. I called you in or I called in to
you about a year ago, but just to briefly
sum it up, I pretty much was having an issue
with my family where they were all convinced
that Joe Biden was the only person who could
win in 2020. I suppose they were correct in
some sense.
Speaker 1: I remember the call. I remember
talking to you about this.
Speaker 6: So I found myself in a new position
now where any time I even mildly critique
Biden, yeah, they call me a Trumpet's and
assume that I'm coming at it from a right
wing perspective. Right. Even as I try to
explain my left wing perspective.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's you know, I've dealt
with this a little bit during my you know,
during the Trump era, I would cover the press
briefings of Kayleigh McEnany or McEnany or
Marghani, as some of them call her. And I
would just give my thoughts in real time.
And similarly, now, under Biden, I will cover
the Jen Psaki press briefings. And of course,
Jen Psaki is not a liar like Kayleigh McEnany
was. The substance, the level of substance
is up dramatically with Jen Psaki relative
to Kayleigh McEnany. You know, it's like a
90 10. It's a huge difference. But sometimes
Jen Psaki will, like, not really answer a
question or she'll say something that doesn't
make sense. Like, for example, the Biden tax
plan will not increase taxes on individuals
nor on families earning under four hundred
thousand. And someone will ask, well, hold
on. Is it is that is it on individuals or
families? Because usually for families it's
twice the individual. And she says it's both.
And it's like that doesn't make any sense.
And I'll point that out and I'll get emails
from people saying, how dare you how dare
you criticize Jen Psaki. She's great. And
it's like guys, you know. Nope, none of these
people are infallible. And just because we
point out that something doesn't make sense
doesn't mean that we're on the right all of
a sudden.
Speaker 6: Yeah, and that's kind of the argument
I've tried to make, though I I met with a
lot of resistance.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't know what to do to
deal with that because it's like do you have
to clarify every time just to be I you know,
it's like in family or do you have to say
I support Joe Biden over Trump and thought
Trump was despicable. But when Joe Biden said
X, I don't think that that was accurate. Like,
that's a crazy way to have to communicate,
especially with family.
Speaker 6: I agree that's what I'm doing currently.
Speaker 1: Oh, it is. That's how you do it,
you frame it that way.
Speaker 6: I pretty much have to you know,
they they're a little bit more responsive,
you know, at least when I tell them I did
vote for Biden, but it's it's a lot of the
same oath. Oh, no. Biden is basically infallible.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: If you find some way to better
grease the wheels on those conversations,
let me know. Sure. All right, my pleasure.
Great to hear from you. Yeah, that's that's
that's a sad set of circumstances, that's
for sure. OK, why don't we go to John Paul
Jones now, John Paul Jones. I remember we've
spoken before because you didn't know that
the Led Zeppelin bassist was John Paul Jones
last time you were on. Right.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, thanks for having me
on. Yeah, I just wanted to say a few a couple
of things. First of all, first of all, I just
want to say say thank you for talking me out
of considering and voting for a third party
last summer. That wasn't the main reason why
I backed away from voting for third party.
But that was kind of the thing that pushed
me over the edge like, no, I'm not going to
do that. So I just wanted to say thank you
for that. Thank you. And then. Also, I just
wanted to say I'm actually I'm in the process
of starting a new progressive blog right now
for my self, and I just was wondering if you
and my other progressive I would just like
to read the first draft of my first blog article
on Valleywag.
Speaker 1: Sure. Send it to me through my
website. I will take a look at it.
Speaker 2: OK, do you know how to contact
Kyle? I've been trying to get in contact with
him, but I just haven't been able to
Speaker 1: I do not it would not be appropriate
for me to do that.
Speaker 2: OK, well, OK, so how are they going
to put your Web site,
Speaker 1: you go to the contact page on my
website.
Speaker 2: OK, OK, thanks. I just send out.
It will be it will be about about a week or
so before it might be far before I put down
my put on my blog, maybe so I'll just send
it to you and maybe you can read it.
Speaker 1: Perfect. All right. Very nice.
That's a plan.
Speaker 2: OK, and I just wanted to say I
just wanted to say thank you. Thank you again.
Again, because I wasn't I remember listening
to that call after it was uploaded to YouTube.
And I remember thinking, man, I was at it.
Speaker 1: Oh, my goodness. OK, we're going
to bleep that. But I appreciate the call.
All right. John Paul Jones, very, very strong.
Speaker 2: I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry
for cursing.
Speaker 1: Great to hear from you. OK, my
pleasure. He's shot out of a cannon today.
That is really something else